chapter 2 seed theory
life is either a daring adventure or
nothing at
all helen keller the energy of a single
thought
may determine the motion of a universe
nikola tesla
when a human's basic needs are met
they unleash wildly fruitful gifts
if their roots are deprived of nutrients
there will be less fruit if any at all
cornerstones in our youth have compound
interest on our life trajectory
each human uses north star perception
nsp as a compass for actualization
analogy nsp is like monte carlo tree
search
mcts in computer science
every decision leads down different
branches
on our tree of possibility top
it's critical to be vigilant with the
input stream into our neural real estate
nre to get really good at parsing
for signal toward nsp
we aim for high signal to noise
to reside in heaven well-being
along the way we are challenged with
tests of faith
tof can you take the necessary leaps to
pursue your highest
goals can you delay your gratification
to get
two marshmallows instead of one
when a significant trauma occurs how
resilient are you to quickly bounce back
the efficacy and speed at which you heal
and resume your trajectory is a crucial
trait
can you go into long periods of deep
work on mastery sprints toward your
goals
i believe nsp north star perception
gift actualization plays a
serious role in the nature of reality
trajectory mechanics no tree
it is said can grow to heaven unless
its roots reach down to hell carl jung
do what is meaningful not what is
expedient
jordan peterson
analogy applying newton's laws of motion
to the evolution of consciousness
inertia is the resistance of
consciousness
to upgrade its perception cognitive
dissonance
the feather rarely triggers an evolution
of consciousness
whereas the sludge hammer acts as a
strong forcing function to awaken
become wiser and share
sri aurobindo and the mother mira alfasa
were the first people that
introduced me to the spiritual ascent
and descent
happening simultaneously
it is ironic that isaac newton said
i can calculate the motion of heavenly
bodies but not the madness of people
when his very laws enable great insight
into a synthesis between physics and
consciousness
you